listen to that hear that bird yeah we
have a wild pack of parrots around here
too green parrots yeah there's a lot of
do you think that was a domestic pet
that escaped and they live a long time
don't they i believe so right yeah and
then are they
when they when they make that noise are
they laughing at humans that they escape
yeah let me see if i can summon one down
because i lately can talk to animals
nope okay couldn't pull it off that's
pretty cool did you say something no
what was that noise
oh was
no seriously what is it are we in a
flight path is that an airplane that's a
loud one no no that's a motorcycle yeah
i think it's a motorcycle who said
i'm looking at my audio specialists yeah
who work in the audio world and they're
all like airplane they're and then blay
makes this makes a gesture of a
motorcycle yeah and they're all like
yeah yeah motorcycle those are quite
different machines parades
that's either an airplane or a
two-wheeled machine do you know how many
people looked up too
there are eight people here and everyone
mimed a different mode of transportation
the parrots are laughing at us
don't know the sound of an airplane
um this is heaven we escaped your
bondage um what a dick that buried it i
always i have to say i'm going to say
this last thing
and my brother neal agrees with me a
bird calling always makes me laugh
because i always pictu whenever a bird's
like
and it will sometimes take me out of a
movie and you know like the iconic
ending of the godfather when um
they're talking
what's his name uh
the brother-in-law josh who killed sonny
carlo carlo they're talking to carlo and
they pretty much tell us
[Applause]
josh we never should have let you in the
family judge
there's no one there's no one named josh
in the godfather connie married someone
named josh can we trust him i don't know
get a job but not in the family
i love that
job not even i love it i love that josh
trying to become a maid guy and they
bring josh into a room and they're like
this is a great sacred oath you will now
become made into this thing of ours yeah
man that's pretty cool [ __ ] a right
well first of all we need to record your
first name oh you got it josh that's
j-a-u-s-h
josh hey man probably gonna hit the curb
later with some skating and rock some
tunes i don't think this is gonna happen
josh where do i get a gun
um anywho yeah i always think just so in
that scene they're telling carlo
you know um carlo we know that stunt
that you pulled you think it was gonna
fall and in the background you hear cool
cool and i always laugh
i
when there's a bird on a branch calling
i always they immediately take and the
same thing happens with a horse if i'm
watching a movie and and something
really dramatic is happening and there's
a horse in the scene yeah i look at the
horse and i know the horse doesn't give
a [ __ ] yeah and i completely lose it i
just start laughing so in the godfather
scene it's the scene where they
basically busted carlo first yes but he
doesn't know he's to die yet no just
kind of telling him we know spoiler
alert oh trust me it's time
if you thought that josh is in the
godfather then then you don't deserve to
watch the godfather but anyway watch
that scene because they're saying like
you think that would fool a corleone and
then you hear [ __ ] but it sounds like
the bird is saying caught caught yeah
yeah it kind of does the birds sort of
like [ __ ] you
carlo you're gonna die
you think you're getting away but you're
not gonna anyway uh this is a chill
chums we're drinking yeah we're having a
wonderful time let's take a look at
where we are with our drinks just as we
can
i'm almost done i'm almost done too
i'd say sona's mostly done i'm i'm mom
i'm going down you're going super you're
baby bear dude yeah yeah yeah
because i got a i got to steer this boat
but sona go crazy yeah i'm she's walking
home tonight all right i'm gonna uh i'm
gonna take us out of here every time i
try one of you starts mumbling and
bumbling sorry okay so now let's go over
the hand signals one more time closed
hand means don't talk don't talk open
hands don't talk
straight hand don't talk
when i make a pyramid don't talk five
fingers don't talk two fingers don't
talk
thumbs down don't talk and thumbs up
don't talk got it yeah i think we're in
good shape come on come on
all right